okay today I'm going to talk to you
about biodiversity and two particular
things that humans do that can impact
biodiversity so first of all we need to
know what biodiversity means so it
basically means variety of organisms in
an ecosystem organisms means living
things so if there's a high biodiversity
it just means there's a large variety of
different living things within an
ecosystem so the two things that we're
going to look at that influence that can
basically negatively impact biodiversity
fish farming and non-indigenous species
in the genus species so both of these
things are things that people do that
can reduce biodiversity which is a bad
thing so essentially we're going to
start with fish farming so fish farming
is basically where where people make
Nets they they've have nets in open
water like in a lake or in in the sea
and they have the fish within these nets
so the water is all around obviously but
the fish cannot get out through the
holes in the net so all of your fish are
in here it makes it easier to catch the
fish it makes them easier to feed the
fish and so this is why people do fish
farming however it can have a negative
effect on biodiversity and here is here
are the reasons why basically as the
farmers as the fish farmers add the food
and some of the food is not eaten and it
goes to waste
also these fish are producing waste as
well both of these things can lead to
something called eutrophication now you
to vacation basically causes algae to
grow over the surface of the water and
can reduce by a diverse
you can watch another video about
unification on this channel so eautiful
is one of the negative impacts caused by
the waste of caused by the food from
fish farming another negative impact is
for parasites and disease so remember
these fish even though they're within
the net they can parasites that are on
the fish can escape and infect other
organisms that are in the water so fish
farming could be a really negative
another negative impact on the
biodiversity because these parasites
could end up damaging and affecting the
numbers of other organisms the final
problem is is this trapped predators so
remember even though these that there
are these these nets outside of the nets
is open water so predators such as sea
lions can come along and try to catch
the fish and actually get entangled and
die within the nets so again that is
going to affect the biodiversity that's
going to decrease the biodiversity by
killing certain predators so that is
basically for the negative impact of
fish farming the other thing that we're
going to look at the negatively impacts
biodiversity is non-indigenous species
the example I'm going to use is by
looking at crayfish so this here is the
UK crayfish and this here is the bigger
one is called the signal crayfish so
essentially in the UK we use they're
just used to have this type of crayfish
here now what basically what happened is
the signal crayfish was introduced to
the UK it was actually from from America
in order to kind of boost the food
source so people would have these nice
big crayfish to eat so they're
introduced to river systems across the
UK so the difference between indigenous
and non-indigenous indigenous means that
organism is originally from that
particular area so in this context the
UK crayfish was the indigenous one it
was originally
on the area the non-indigenous organism
is the one that has been introduced in
this particular context it's the signal
crayfish now with the introduction of a
non-indigenous species comes three main
and negative impacts first of all
competition for resources if we have two
different organisms that are both
competing for the same resource for
example food
one might out-compete the other meaning
and reduction in the population of the
of one of the species so what that's one
impact that the signal crayfish had
another is predation so the signal
crayfish could prey on different
organisms and cause those numbers to
decrease their populations decrease
again reducing biodiversity and the
final one is the signal crayfish could
bring disease so this introduced species
could bring disease along with them that
could end up wiping out or reducing the
numbers of other organisms so this is
how non-indigenous species can decrease
the biodiversity thank you